à l'occasion de faire mexpo le grand
rendez-vous de l'agriculture en région
qui débute demain on s'intéresse aux
problématiques du secteur c'est la suite
de notre rubrique en direct de nos
fermes
intéresse ce soir à ces exploitations
qui produisent de l'énergie une
soixantaine d'unités de méthanisation vu
le jour ces dernières années en
Centre-Val de Loire le lisier et les
déchets alimentaires sont transformés en
gaz ou en électricité exemple dans cette
usine de Saint-Paterne Racan alimenté
par les fermes les fermes environnantes
les la Turquie
c'est l'heure du ravitaillement au menu
du jour 560 kg de déchets alimentaires
venus tout droit d'une cantine du coin
et réutiliser pour produire de l'énergie
naturellement dans la nature et ben on a
du méthane qui se dégage de ces matières
là donc là on va venir le capter dans
les poches de gaz qu'on peut avoir là
derrière sur les bassins on produit de
l'électricité et de la chaleur après
avec la chaleur des moteurs qui montent
en température pour être complètement
autonome pour chauffer nos bassins et 40
degrés ici 20 000 tonnes de matière sont
traitées par an pour fournir en moyenne
800 kWh d'électricité injecter
directement sur le réseau EDF une
recette bien rodée avec un équilibre
entre déchets alimentaires et effluents
d'élevage venus de cette exploitation
différente pour une collecte de méthane
optimisée le jour comme de nuit ça vient
alimenter dans le dans le bassin la
pratique est de plus en plus répandue il
existe maintenant une quinzaine de
méthaniseurs en Indre-et-Loire mais la
quantité de déchets elle n'augmente pas
on va pas faire de la surproduction pour
alimenter des mécaniseurs donc faut
qu'il y ait une certaine logique par
rapport à une cartographie à mon avis
sur la matière organique disponible pour
alimenter les méthaniseurs à partir de
2024 il sera interdit aux particuliers
de jeter leur déchets compostables dans
la poupée grise alors bio énergie
Touraine cherche déjà des alternatives
comme par exemple des points de collecte
sous forme de conteneurs réfrigérés qui
pourraient ensuite alimenter leur
méthaniseur